hello and welcome to
the empirical risk minimization section
this section is in many ways the heart
of the class
empirical risk minimization is the
process by which
predictors are learned from data
so many of the predictors that we've
seen in fact many predictors overall
have a parametrized form we think about
y-hat is g of x and theta
where g is a function that determines
the structure or the form of the
predictor
it might be a neural network or it might
be a linear predictor
or it might be a tree and theta
is a set of parameters there might be a
vector of a matrix or some other
data structure and that set of
parameters is going to
be one of the determinants
that produces the output y hat
and when we learn we're going to learn
by choosing the parameters theta and
we're going to leave g
fixed so for example we might consider
linear regression and if y is scalar
then we'd have y hat would be g
theta of x and here g theta of x would
take the form
theta 1 times x 1 plus theta 2 times x 2
all the way up to theta d times x d
and so theta here is a parameter
it's a d dimensional vector and we might
write
y hat is theta transpose multiplied
by x we also might have a predictor
for a vector y in r m
um and if that's a linear regression
model
then we would have y hat as g theta of x
is also c to 1 times x 1 plus theta 2
times x 2
all the way up to theta d times x d but
here each of the theta i's
is an m dimensional vector and the x's
x 1 through x d are the coefficients
which determine a linear combination of
the vectors
theta one sub theta d
often we would write that in terms of a
matrix
so we'd write our matrix theta which is
a d by m
matrix and the ith row of that matrix
is theta i transpose and then we can
express
the relationship y hat as g theta
of x as y hat is theta transpose
times x just as before
we might have other types of predictors
as well we might have a tree prediction
model
in which case theta would encode the
tree it would tell us the thresholds
at each of the vertices of the tree and
the leaf values
now we're going to choose which
particular theta to use
based on some training data we're going
to have n
data pairs x i y
i if i is one up to n
and that's going to be the training data
we will use it to fit the model
and this is called the training process
and there's many different training
processes that vary based on what kind
of predictor
we're choosing to fit and what our
performance metric is so
for example if we're training a linear
regression model
and if y is scalar then we might use
something like least squares
we would choose theta to minimize the
sum
over all the data points i is 1 up to n
of y i minus the predicted value
y hat i squared and this notation y
hat i is what it means
is g evaluated at x
i so y hat i
is the prediction when the predictor
is fed with the ith value of x
and as a result we say well we're going
to
choose theta to minimize the
sum of the squares of the prediction
error
which is the sum from is one to n of g
theta of x
i minus y i squared
that's a very reasonable way of learning
a predictor
in this lecture we'll actually cover a
more
general method which is very widely used
and it's very effective and it's called
empirical
risk minimization and
what it is at its heart is a
generalization of the least squares
idea
and the way this works is we have a loss
function
a loss function takes two vectors as its
input
a y hat and a y and it gives you back a
real number
and it quantifies how close
y hat is to y really what it does is it
quantifies how badly y hat approximates
y
because normally the loss
function of y hat and y is small when y
hat
is close to y and large when y hat is
different from y
so if the loss function is small we'll
say that y hat is really a good
approximation of y
and if the loss function is large we'll
say it's a bad approximation of y
and it's very common that we actually
arrange things
so the loss function evaluated
when y is equal to y is zero
and the loss function when y hat is not
equal to y
is non-negative
so there are some very common examples
the first is uh
the quadratic loss function i've got a
scalar y
and therefore a scalar y hat the
quadratic loss is just
y hat minus y squared
if i've got vectors for y and y hat then
the quadratic loss
is the two norm or the euclidean norm
of y hat minus y squared which is just
the sum
of the squares of the differences
between y hat i and y i
uh another common loss is the absolute
loss
the if i've got scalar y and scalar y
hat again
then the absolute loss is just the
absolute value of y hat minus y
here's another loss this is the maximum
of y hat divided by y minus 1
and y divided by y hat minus 1.
so this is the fractional loss
or the relative loss so if y
hat is 20
more than y then y hat over y minus one
will be point two
and uh if y hat is
uh twenty percent less
than y then y over y hat minus one will
be point 0.2
another convenient way of expressing
this is as the exponential
of the absolute value of the log of y
hat minus the log of y
minus 1. and often we might scale it by
and then it really is percentage error
we often use fractional loss for
quantities which either range over very
wide
range of magnitudes
we saw last time the example of
website visits which can range over many
orders of magnitude
another case where we might use
fractional loss
is where we're dealing with prices where
very often we're more concerned with the
percentage difference in two prices
than the absolute difference in two
prices
and we'll see particular interpretations
of these losses and cases where
some of them are better more naturally
suited than others
and we will also see many other possible
loss functions
in this class
now we start off with a loss function
and using it we construct something
called the empirical
risk and the empirical risk is just the
average loss
over the data points so in order to
compute the empirical risk we need
to have a bunch of data we need to have
a predictor
and we need to have a loss function and
then
for each data point we simply compute
the loss
between g theta of x i and y
i and then in order to compute
the empirical risk we average that loss
over all the data points
and then if the empirical risk is small
the predictor does a good job on average
over all the data at least according to
the particular loss function that we've
chosen
we usually write the empirical risk
as a function of the theta that
parameterizes the predictor
of course it's also a function of the
data set
but we suppress that in the notation
and you might say well this is quite
similar to what we talked about before
when we talked about performance metrics
that's absolutely true
in both cases we're measuring how well a
predictor does
the difference is that performance
metric is something that we use
to judge how well our predictor
is doing whereas empirical risk is
something that we're going to use to
train
the model we're going to train the
predictor we're going to choose which
predictor we're going to use
according to a procedure which is
trying to make the empirical risk small
and very often empirical risk and
performance metrics are the same and you
might say well why not just choose the
empirical risk equal to the performance
metric
and we're going to have some quite some
details to
say about that in the in the rest of
this class
and usually what we try and do is we try
and pick empirical risk to correspond to
performance metric
sometimes training works better when you
don't do that
here's some more examples of uh
empirical risk
for example if you've got quadratic loss
and scalar y
well then the empirical risk is the mean
square
error if you've got
scalar y and you're using an absolute
loss function
then the empirical risk is the mean
absolute error
so let's talk about empirical risk
minimization
it's the method according to which we
choose theta
and the idea is very simple choose theta
to minimize the empirical risk
um and
one way to say that is to say what we're
doing with theta is we're trying
to make the average loss small
over the entire data set it's a way of
getting
our predictor to match up with the data
set well
sometimes you can actually solve
empirical risk minimization
exactly analytically
in particular if g of theta is a linear
predictor
and uh we're using a square loss
function
then the empirical risk minimization
problem
is the least squares problem and
that's something that we can solve
analytically
there's an explicit formula for the
optimal theta
in most cases it doesn't work like that
most cases there is no analytic solution
to the minimization problem
there's no formula and
instead we have to use numerical
optimization
to find a theta that minimizes the
empirical risk
and usually it's actually slightly worse
than that in that the numerical
procedures that we use
cannot guarantee to find the theta that
actually minimizes the
empirical risk but instead can only
guarantee to
approximately minimize the empirical
risk
um but there are also reasons why
that's okay we typically don't want or
need a seeder that is a perfect
minimizer but an approximate minimizer
is fine
and we'll have more to say on that as
well
now the particular value of theta that
you get the particular predictor that
you get
depends on the particular loss that you
chose
and how are we going to determine which
loss we should choose given that we've
seen
mean square error
mean absolute error mean fractional
error
in many other potential loss functions
and the answer to these kinds of
questions is always the same
we validate we validate against some
external
test set um
and when we do the validation we don't
always
validate with the same
error measure that we've chosen to train
with we don't validate
with the risk we validate with the
performance metric
now there's one more wrinkle that we add
to empirical
risk minimization which it turns out can
make it work
a lot better
and that is this thing called
regularization
and regularization works as follows
we're very concerned when we're
training a predictor that we don't
over fit the predictor we don't have a
predictor that is tuned
very well to features of
the training data that
aren't features that are generically
in the data in other words if we take
some other data set from the same
phenomena
that we want to make sure that our
predictor is tuned well to those
features that
occur in that other data set as well
and not to particular wiggles that only
showed up in our training set
the way we do that is we
look at the sensitivity of the predictor
we look at it's how
much it responds to small
changes in x
so we would call a predictor d theta
insensitive
if for some x near x tilde
g theta of x is also near
g theta of x dollar
way to say it is that if the features
are close then the predictions will also
be close
there are many ways that you can make
this more mathematically
precise um one is the notion of
continuity
um and there are other more quantitative
notions than continuity as well
um but the key point is not so much how
you measure the sensitivity of the
predictor
it's the benefit you get by making a
which is insensitive
to the features
x you make a predictor that generalizes
well
to your new data set and that's
particularly important when you don't
have a lot of
training data
so insensitivity is a good attribute for
a predictor to have
despite sounding like a bad one
and a regularizer that's a function
of theta that measure measures how
sensitive
the predictor g theta is so
the regularizer is a function r it takes
as input theta and it returns a real
number so
here we've used our p to indicate
the space in which theta lives
in some p dimensional space and
if y is scalar and we're using a
linear predictor then p is equal to d
if y is m dimensional and
x is d dimensional then p is equal to d
times
m and if we're using a neural network
then p might be a much larger number
so r theta is chosen such that it's
small
when g theta is insensitive and
it's large when g theta was sensitive
there are some cases where we can
in a straightforward way quantify how
sensitive a predictor is um
so for example in a linear regression
model where g of theta of
x is theta transpose x
then the small
sensitivity corresponds to small
theta and the way to see then
is to look at what's called the koshi
shivats inequality
remember the koshi schwarz inequality
let me write it down
it says that if i've got two vectors p
and q and i look at p transpose q
the absolute value of p transpose q is
less than or equal to
the two norm of p multiplied by the two
norm
of q
we're going to need a slight
generalization of that just to say the
following result
so suppose g theta of x is theta
transpose x
and i look at the sensitivity by
measuring the norm of the difference
between g theta of x and g theta of x
dollar
well that's equal to the norm of theta
transpose
multiplied by x minus x tilde
the norm of theta transpose
x minus x tilde
is less than or equal to the norm of
theta
multiplied by the norm of x minus x
tilde
now the tricky thing here is the choice
of norm that we use for that inequality
um and first of all let me
uh remind you of the result we're using
first of all
theta transpose times a vector x
the absolute value is less than or equal
to the norm
of theta two norm times the norm
of x in the tunnel now this is true
when both theta and x are vectors
so here we've got theta
is in our d and x is in r
d now i want to also consider
the case where y is not a scalar but y
is a vector and then we must look at
what happens when we multiply a matrix
times a vector
and ask if there's a simple way of
constructing a bound
on that quantity so here
let's consider a matrix a
and look at the two norm of
the matrix a times
the vector x and
we can we know what that is that's the
sum
over i is 1
up to m of a
i transpose x
squared i'm going to make that squared
where here what i've done
is i've written a
in terms of its rows
a1 transpose up to a
m transpose so each little a
i here is a vector
in r d and a
here is a matrix in
r m by
d
now this quantity here a i transpose x
well we know how to bound that
because that comes from the
straightforward kashi schwarz inequality
so this is less than or equal to the sum
over
i is one up to m of
the norm of a i two norm squared
the norm of x two norm squared
using the square of the kashishvarts
inequality
now of course we can put parentheses
around that because
the x doesn't depend on i and this
this quantity here
is the sum of the norm squareds
of each of the com column of each of the
rows
of the matrix a in each row
of a matrix a we can calculate its norm
squared by taking the sum of the squares
of its entries
and then if we sum over all the rows
what we've effectively done
is taken the sum of the squares of all
of the entries of a so that's equal to
the sum over i one
up to m the sum over j
is one up to d of the norm of
a i j and it's not the norm of a i j
of a i j squared
multiplied by the norm of x squared
and this quantity is known
as the frobenius norm squared
of a matrix and it's the analog of the
euclidean norm
of a vector it just takes the sum of the
squares of all of the entries of the
matrix a and square groups them
so we can apply that result
to our predictor our vector predictor
and we find that the norm
of theta transpose x minus x tilde is
less than or equal to the frobenius norm
of f
multiplied by the norm of x minus x
tilde
and this suggests that well maybe we
should use as a regularizer
the norm of theta squared
in the framinius norm and that is
one possible choice and it's very common
choice for a regularizer
if we keep the regularizer small we
choose
a theta that makes rfc to small then we
will make
our predictor
less sensitive to x
now when y is scalar the most common
regularizer to use
is simply the sum of the squares of the
components of theta
the two norm of theta squared
that has a name that's called ridge
regularization
for vector y we take the sum
of the squares of all of the entries of
the matrix theta the frobenius norm of
theta squared
that's also called ridge regularization
another very popular regularizer
is to take the one norm of theta
when theta is a vector that's the sum of
the absolute values
of the entries of theta and when
theta is a matrix instead of a vector we
take the sum
over all of the entries
of theta we take the sum of the absolute
values of all of the entries of theta
now when there is a constant feature
for example when x1 is 1
um then we do something slightly
different when we're doing
regularization
this often happens because we very often
would like
to have a predictor with a constant
terminal
so for example if g theta
is a linear predictor then g theta of x
is theta transpose x
and if x1
is chosen to be 1 then g theta of x will
be theta 1
plus theta 2 transpose times the
remaining components
of x we also do this when we have
neural network predictors
in the general matrix case g theta of x
will look like theta transpose
x but now the first component
which corresponds to x1 is 1 will be
the first row of theta here we've
written that as theta 1
comma colon
and so the resulting predictor will be g
theta of x is theta 1 comma colon
transpose
plus theta 2 colon d
comma colon transpose x 2 colon d
here let's be explicit about what the
notation means
the notation here means the following if
i have
a 2 3 comma
4 7 that means take a slice
out of the matrix which consists of the
second
and third rows
and the columns four five six and seven
i can also write things like this
a two colon three comma colon which
means take
the entire second and third rows
in every column
and this is notation that's used by
matlab and julia
and it's also now spread its way
back from programming into mathematics
so g theta of x is constant plus a
linear term
in x now the constant terms don't affect
the sensitivity
we can see this if we evaluate g theta
of x minus g
theta of x tilde then we get
the constant term simply cancelling out
and we're left with
the theta 2 colon d transpose
multiplied by x minus x tilde
now as a result there's no need to
regularize the first row of theta
if x1 is constant and we use a
regularizer which is simply
a norm or some other function of the
remaining
entries of theta and we might use the
frobenius norm squared
of the last d minus one rows of theta
and that brings us to regularized erm
that's a method where we instead of
choosing a
theta that simply minimizes the
empirical risk
l of theta we also try to find a theta
that trades off the
insensitivity of the predictor
and the way it does that is
we find try to find a theta which makes
both l of theta small
and r of c to small
the way you do that is by a technique
called regularized erm
where we choose theta to minimize the
weighted sum
l of theta plus lambda times r of theta
lambda here is a non-negative number
it's a parameter it's called the
regularization hyperparameter
and parameter here means that instead of
it being a parameter that's
learned from the training data directly
it's a parameter we're going to choose
via
a different process which i will tell
you about
in a second now when lambda's zero
regularized drm just reduces to erm
when lambda is very large then
theta that minimizes l of theta plus
lambda r of theta
is going to be very close to the theta
that just minimizes rf theta
and so we're going to end up with a
predictor which is very insensitive but
may not do very well
at fitting the predicted data
and so when lambda takes intermediate
values between zero
and very large well then we're going to
get some balance
between minimizing l of theta and
minimizing r of theta
and in most cases you cannot solve
regularized drm
exactly just as you can't solve erm
exactly
and so we use numerical optimization
so with erm you're just minimizing the
empirical risk l of theta
and you're choosing the theta that does
that
with rerm because you are adding
on this term to the objective function
lambda times
rf theta the theta that you get does not
minimize
the empirical risk in other words it's
not
producing the predictor that best fits
the training data
it's producing a predictor that fits the
training data worse than the rm
predictor
but it is less sensitive than the erm
because the what you gain
is you get a predictor that's making the
regularizer small
now the benefit here is that a predictor
that's less sensitive
often generalizes better it
makes better predictions on unseen data
than the predictor that fits the
training data as well as possible
and this is what you see in practice is
that
even though there's there's a predictor
which is the era predictor that does the
best
on the training data
that predictor when you take it and try
it on unseen data
it's not the best predictor and you get
a better predictor
on unseen data by
finding a predictor which solves the
rerm
minimization problem which backs off a
little bit
from fitting the data as well as
possible
and instead compromises
and chooses a theta
which is less sensitive
we still have to say how do we choose
these things how do we choose the
regularizer and how do we choose the
regularization parameter
lambda and ultimately the answer is the
same for
all of these questions use validation
you have a performance metric
look at the predictor that you got and
try it out
on some unseen data and see how well it
does pick the one that does the best
for lambda in particular there's a very
specific technique called
regularization hyper parameter search
and that's for choosing
lambda and the way this works is that
you choose a set
of values of lambda say 50 between say
10 to the minus 5
and 10 to the 5 and usually
logarithmically spaced
and for each one of those lambda values
you solve the rerm problem you minimize
l of theta plus lambda times r of theta
now for each lambda value you're going
to get a different theta you're going to
get a different predictor and so theta
you get a bunch of different seed values
50 different ceta values
50 different theta vectors and that's
called the regularization path
now with each of those 50 different
theta values we have a corresponding
predictor
and we can evaluate the performance of
those predictors
on the test set
and what we do is we choose the value of
lambda that gives the best test
performance
and the corresponding predictor is the
one we use
now there's a particular case for which
we can
solve erm and rerm exactly
and those are called least squares and
ridge regression
and i'm going to review least squares
and then tell you about bridge
regression
so when we have a square loss
and a linear predictor we can solve the
erm problem explicitly exactly
analytically
we have a predictor g theta of x is
theta transpose x
we have data consisting of n pairs
x i y i
now the empirical risk is
the average of the loss of the predictor
evaluated
at each of the data points compared with
so the loss is evaluated at a prediction
value
theta transpose x i and the true y
i at that point
now in our case the loss is just
quadratic
and so this is theta transpose x i minus
y i
squared and if y is a vector
then this should really be the norm
l of theta should be 1 on n
the sum from i is 1 up to n
of the norm of c to transpose x i
minus y i squared
now we're going to express this in a
convenient matrix form
as the frobenius norm of x theta minus y
squared divided by n to do this we will
construct two matrices
x and y x is an n by d
matrix whose ice row is the ice feature
vector
x i transposed and y
is an n by m matrix whose ice row
is the ith target vector
y i transposed
now when we look at
this expression x theta minus y
that's a matrix its first row
is simply x1 transposed theta
minus y1 transpose x second row is x2
transpose theta
minus y2 transposed and so on
now the norm squared
of the prediction error
the so the loss at the first data point
is the norm squared of that row
and that's just the sum of the squares
of the entries in the row
i'd like to compute the empirical risk
in order to do that i've got to sum up
all
of the different norm squareds all of
the different losses
and divide them by n so that's just the
sum of the squares
of all of the entries in this matrix
divided by n and that's one on n
times the frobenius norm of that matrix
squared
and now i've got to choose the theta
that minimizes
that quantity now
let's do a quick review of least squares
suppose i had this problem minimize the
norm
of x w minus v
squared that's a
least squares problem and here w and v
are vectors
what's the solution to this well we've
seen this before
in our linear algebra class this the
optimal solution
is x transpose x
inverse x transpose
b we're minimizing over w
and we can get this by expanding this
norm
and differentiating for example
now suppose i want to solve
our more complicated problem
x theta minus y for a benious norm
squared
where theta is now a matrix
i can do that by writing
theta in terms of its columns
w1 w2 up to wm
and y in terms of its columns y1
y2 up to ym
and then the ith column
of x theta minus y is simply x
w i minus y i
now the frobenius norm squared of a
matrix is the sum of the squares
of the of the euclidean norm of the
columns
so this quantity
is the sum over i is one up to m
of the norm of x w i minus y
i squared
now i've got to minimize this quantity
and i'm minimizing it
by choosing the w i's
now this is a sum with m terms
and the i term in this sum only depends
on w
i and so in order to minimize
this sum i choose the w1 to minimize the
first term
the w2 to minimize the second term and
so on
each one of those minimizers looks like
this
it's a least squares problem and so the
answer to the individual
least squares problem
looks like that
and that means that when i stack all
these columns next to each other
i find that w is x transpose
x inverse x
transpose y
and so we can solve a matrix least
squares problem
in the frobenius norm
by solving m separately squares problems
and it turns out that the matrix
inside each of those least squares
problems is the same
it's simply x transpose x inverse x
transpose
so i just need to solve that once
multiply it by y
and that will give me all of the w's at
once which is the matrix w
that i wanted i guess i called that
matrix
theta rather than w let's call it theta
so that gives us the minimizing theta
x dagger times y which is just x
transpose x
inverse x transpose y this is called
least
squares regression
now if we're doing regularized
erm and we've got a regularizer
which is the norm squared of theta
and we've got square loss as in our loss
function
and we've got a linear predictor and we
can solve our erm
exactly as well and this is called
ridge regression
the reim objective function
is just like our erm objective function
with one extra term
the extra term being lambda
times the norm of theta squared where
the norm is the frobenius norm
and so the overall
objective has two terms both of which
are matrix norms in
theta now
i can express this in a convenient way
i can stack up my two expressions
my two different normal expressions to
make one normal expression
now in order to make sense of this
expression here we will notice the
following things
first of all if i've got two matrices a
b multiplied by theta
that just works out to be a theta
b theta
the second is that
if i'm looking at the norm
of a theta b theta
and that's the frobenius norm squared
well that's just the sum of the squares
of the entries of the matrix so i can
break that up very conveniently
as the norm of a theta
f squared plus the norm
of b theta f squared
and if i use those two facts
i can see that this is going to have
this product here is going to be x theta
minus y in the top
block and the bottom block is going to
be root n
lambda theta and then i'm going to take
the norm
squared of both of those blocks
separately and end up with
my expression for
the objective function of regularized
erm
now this problem
is precisely of the form
that we had for erm it's just got a
larger matrix here
and a larger matrix here
remember that in the erm problem when i
was trying to solve the minimum
over theta of the norm of
a theta minus b
for venus norm squared there was an
explicit answer
which was theta is equal to a transpose
a
inverse a transpose b
so here i simply need to compute this
matrix
x on top of root n lambda identity
transposed times itself inversed
times the same matrix again times the b
matrix which is y
zero and that works out to be
this expression here first the optimal
theta
and just to see that
if i work out x
root n lambda identity
transpose x
i get x transpose x
plus n lambda identity
now when lambda is greater than zero so
happens that this inverse always exists
i don't need the usual assumption that
the
columns of x are linearly independent
and so we can explicitly solve ridge
regression
in the case which is
rerm in the case where we've got a
quadratic loss
quadratic regularizer and a linear
predictor
we can here's a julia implementation
given a matrix x and a matrix y and it
will return for you
the corresponding theta matrix
here is the case where we don't
regularize the first
row of theta the only thing it changes
is that we multiply theta
inside the regularization term by e
where e is a matrix which has
zero for its first column and is a d
minus one by d minus one identity
for its remaining columns and therefore
e
times theta simply picks out the last d
minus one rows of theta
as a result the norm of e theta
squared is precisely the norm that we
wanted
the norm of the last d minus one rows of
theta
that translates just as before
into uh
this larger matrix expression
and when i take the product of this
matrix
transpose times itself i get the extra
term right there e transpose e
e transpose e it's a matrix
which is square and
has a d minus 1 by d minus one identity
in the lower right block and in the top
left block
it just has a zero instead of a one so
it's an identity matrix which is just
missing
one of its ones
and here's a julia implementation of
that case as well
notice that when we write in julia the
code looks very like
the mathematics that's a very convenient
feature
the only perhaps slight difference here
is that there's this nice backslash
function
in julia which is a convenient
shorthand for the explicitly square
solution
that we've seen before so a
backslash b means
a transpose a inverse
a transpose b
at least in the case where a is skinny
and full rank that's exactly what it
means
now let's look at an example of how this
works
in practice this is a data set
for 442 individuals
of which has been measured 10
different indicators for
diabetes and those are our 10
components of u
and x will have 11 components because we
will have a constant feature added on
now the target variable the y is simply
a scalar
and that's some measure of diabetes
progression
over one year there's some biological
indicator of that
and that's on the vertical axis in these
plots
and on the horizontal axis in each one
of these plots
is a different component of u
so the first one here is age we can see
individuals between age
20 and age 80 and some spread over the
resulting
diabetes indicators the second one
is sex and those have been labeled here
as
one or two which is a particular choice
of embedding
for the two possible values in this data
set
we have bmi body mass indicator bp is
blood pressure
and then we have s1 through s6 which are
particular blood serum levels
so we've got this data
and we're going to try and fit it using
erm and rerm
we'll take the data and we'll split it
80 20 so we'll use
80 percent of it for training and 20 of
it we'll use this validation data which
using which we're going using the
and we will use the validation data to
choose
the hyperparameter lambda
we'll use lambda values between ten to
the minus five
and ten to the four
here we look at two plots the first plot
is a plot of the
empirical risk of the optimal theta
as we vary lambda so remember
what the approach is here we've got
lambda values varying between 10 to the
minus
5 and 10 to the 4 and we've got say 50
different values
for each one of those lambda values we
minimize
l of theta plus lambda times r of theta
we get a theta for each one of those
lambda values and
for each one of those thetas we can
compute the empirical risk
on the training data set
that's this plot right here
something to notice is when land is very
small
down here we've got a seater
that is effectively minimizing empirical
risk
and as we increase lambda
well then we're starting to trade off
and instead of minimizing just empirical
risk we're starting to balance out
sensitivity
we can also look at the corresponding r
values the regularizer values
and you can see they go the opposite way
when lambda's very small
the minimizer makes no effort to make r
of theta small and r of theta is just
whatever it happens to
as we increase lambda well suddenly the
minimizer
is compelled to minimize r of theta
instead of minimizing l of theta
when we get over here
we've got rs theta is zero remember
that's the sum of the squares of the
entries of the matrix of
of theta which means we've got a
predictor which is completely zero
so the predictor's not doing anything
it's completely insensitive to the data
so at this end when lambda is very large
we end up with zero predictors
predictors which
are constant they still have the
constant term in there
but the rest of the last d minus one
columns of theta
are zero and at this end of the other
end of the of the
lambdas we end up with predictors which
minimize the empirical risk
as we increase lambda the empirical risk
increases so the fit gets worse
but the sensitivity decreases so the
regularizer gets smaller
now for each value of lambda we have a
theta
theta here is predicting a scalar y
from 11 components of x remember we've
got 10 measured variables
and a constant feature
and so c j is just 11 numbers
it's a 11 dimensional vector so we can
plot those 11 numbers
as we vary lambda and what you can see
is that when lambda is very small they
have some particular values
and then as we move to the right and
increase lambda
the components of theta start to get
smaller
and eventually we end up with all of
theta
zero as we know
the model parameters generally get
smaller because the
the regularized empirical risk
minimization is
starting to focus on minimizing rf theta
which is the same as minimizing the norm
squared of theta
people call regularization shrinkage
because of this phenomena
now this is the important plot
here we have two performance
plots we're looking at mean square error
on the training data that's the blue
plot
and on the test data that's the red plot
as we vary lambda remember we've got 50
different values of lambda
each one for each one of those we have a
predictor
that predictor we can measure its
performance in two ways
once we can measure it on the training
set
and what the other time we can measure
it on the validation set the test set
now we already know what happens on the
training set
as we increase lambda
the training error
the empirical risk measured on the
training set
increases but look what happens
on the test set
as we increase lambda
well yes we are naturally increasing
the training error but because the
predictor generalizes better
because the predictor is less sensitive
it does
better on the test set
at some point we get past the point
where we've
traded off too much performance
and we're making a predictor that's very
insensitive but so insensitive
that it doesn't bother looking at the
data and doesn't bother making a good
prediction
this is the benefit this is why we do
regularization
right here in this plot it's for this
dip there which is where
we see the regularized erm doing better
than the own regularized erm over here
on the validation data which is unseen
data which wasn't used to generate
the predictor and
as a result we might say
pick a value for theta
now we could say let's pick a value for
theta at exactly this minimum
some people do that although actually
you're often better off
by predicting a value of theta
picking a value of theta which is a
little bit to the right
a little bit more insensitive
than the minimizer
as a result we get a little bit extra
insensitivity
here we're only just testing out on one
validation set data set
we might like to be a little bit sure
that it's going to generalize
when we see multiple unseen data sets
and so we put a little bit of extra on
sensitivity in it
so we might choose lambda to be 0.3 or
even 1 for this data set
and here we see regularization it's
improved the performance not by a great
deal in this example
it went from 0.63 down to 0.58 or
something like that
sometimes the benefits are much more
dramatic
and
that depends on the characteristics of
the data and how
much data you have and whether your
particular
structure of your predictor is prone to
overfitting that data
and some sometimes regularization is
massively important
and an unregularized predictor an erm
predictor will
not work at all whereas a
regularized predictor can work very well
to summarize empirical risk is a
function of the parameter
theta that measures the fit on the
training data set
it is often but not always the same as
the performance metric
erm chooses theta to minimize empirical
risk
on the training data set regularized erm
doesn't regularly regularize drm
chooses theta as a trade-off between two
different objectives
the first being small empirical risk are
you a good fit on the training
data and the second being predictor
insensitivity
we choose the loss function and the
regularizer function
by validation using our performance
metric
we choose lambda by validation
now when we have quadratic loss
quadratic regularization
and a linear predictor we can find the
optimal parameters
using least squares and that's either
called least squares regression
when it's unregularized or it's called
ridge regression
when it's regularized in general
for erm when we don't have quadratic
loss so we don't have quadratic
regularizers or we've got complicated
predictors
we have to use numerical optimization
we're going to cover this in detail
later in the course